by the time sons of anarchy finished its
seven season long ride back in 2014 the
fx show had become one of the must-see
crime dramas of its time it doesn't have
the nuance achieved by other critically
acclaimed shows like the wire or
breaking bad but the series lovable band
of rogues is no less entertaining sons
of anarchy follows jack's teller played
by charlie hunnam as he goes through an
existential crisis he discovers that his
long-dead father didn't want the sons of
anarchy motorcycle club redwood original
to be a criminal enterprise funded by
drugs and gun running as communicated
posthumously through a discovered
manuscript john teller's high-minded
ideals and peaceful vision for samcro
basically upends his son's entire world
jax is suddenly pulled between his duty
to his brother's conflicts with his
father's undeclared vision and what jax
himself knows to be right sons of
anarchy is a grimy and unrelenting view
of the criminal underworld but its
rogish characters are somewhat charming
however they do dish out brutal
punishments to anyone who crosses them
notably the series was envisioned as a
modern day retelling of shakespeare's
hamlet jax is the indecisive danish
prince and his father's posthumous words
are a kind of reimagined paternal ghost
i am thy father's spirit
the central conflict between jax clay
played by ron perlman and gemma played
by katie seagal even mirrors the
conflict between hamlet claudius and
gertrude from the elizabethan play
shakespeare's original story is pretty
grim in its own right but sons of
anarchy creator kurt sutter took the fx
series to some dark places even the bard
wasn't willing to conjure
gore
death and torture are splattered across
nearly every single season
since there are so many deaths
throughout the series some moments get
lost in the sea of blood however there's
one particular death from sons of
anarchy that stands above the rest
because of the emotional weight that
comes with it the death of harry opie
winston played by ryan hurst during one
of the sun's brief stints behind bars in
season 5 is emotionally devastating and
many fans are still reeling from the
loss
yes gemma killing tara knowles played by
maggie siff in season 6 is horrific
however the reason opie's death hits
harder is because it's the last
self-destructive step on a long journey
into despair that begins after opie
loses his wife in season one he's
ultimately killed in retaliation for the
death of the daughter of harold parano's
character damon pope his daughter was
accidentally killed by tig played by kim
coates when attacking another club
though he gets to play the hero and save
his brothers through self-sacrifice
opie's final act is as much an escape
for him as anything else
he's running away from a life he'd long
given up living opie volunteers to fight
in prison knowing he's going to be
killed
jacks tig and chibs played by tommy
flanagan watch on in horror as two other
inmates mercilessly beat opie to death
with a pipe to make matters even more
galling the whole thing is facilitated
by a corrections officer who's
presumably in pope's pocket that bond
between opie and the brothers he saves
is what makes it the most impactful
death in the series rolling stone voted
it the fourth best moment in sons of
anarchy overall and it was exceeded only
by sentimental scenes
no other death scene even those
involving main characters comes close
entertainment weekly also ranked opie's
death fourth in the 50 most shocking
moments of the series and his death
nabbed the top spot in a similar list at
goliath
but even after opie's gruesome slaying
sons of anarchy is clearly a series that
continues to loom large in the
imaginations of its fans the show's
enduring impact is enough to fuel
continued discussions on social media
even years after the series took its
final bow the cast were equally
heartbroken over opie's death as a way
of saying goodbye they all shaved
hurst's beard with a samurai sword
hunnam told entertainment weekly i
started crying and then mark boone
started crying by the end of it it was
the catharsis that we'd all hoped it
would be
so rip opie winston don't cry too hard
about it though ryan hurst landed a
sweet gig playing beta on the walking
dead after departing sons of anarchy and
for that we are eternally grateful check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
you